Everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's going to talk to you about some standard blood markers that
are involved with digestive issues in our side of some digestive problems.
These could go, you know, with these signs of other things as well, but this is
You know, there's not a lot of standard blood tests from your CBC or your
completely metabolic panel that are going to be suggestive digestive issues, but there's a few. So we're going to go over some of these.
So we're going to be going over total protein
albumin
globulin, the albumin
globulin ratio or ag ratio
The buns are at the type on air be you and blood urea nitrogen
amylase lipase and eocidophil
So these are the ones that we're going to go over in this section
We will be covering all of the biomarkers in different videos. So
Look for them in different videos. So we're looking at these
It seems like amylase is a little or eocidophilus being a white blood cell is a little out of place
But it does tie to digestion issues. So that's why it's in this section
So albumin and globulin are serum proteins. They're blood proteins on this list
So why are we screening for these because they can show us different nutritional deficiencies?
They can help us assess different functional digestive processes and possible problems and
They're part of our check for dehydration and I'm going to have a video on looking at dehydration and videos on different
specific problems and
You know the corollary to blood tests and what you would see in a blood test
Typically with that specific problem. So look for that
Albumin and globulin have had historically part of an ominous side
That kim pit point more serious disease like cancer as well because it has to do with liver function
So total proteins. So this is the range
You see two lines of that smaller white box the optimal range is 6.9 to 7.4
That second line is the international units
In an international test. So the first line is in a U.S. test 6.9 to 7.4 is optimal range
If you haven't yet seen my video of the difference between standard
lab ranges versus functional
optimal ranges
Make sure you watch that
That's why we show you this box your standard range your
Maybe you went to your doctor and they did a test that you were at 6.2 for total protein. They said it was normal
You're good. You have a normal blood test. Well, we're looking at functional ranges. These optimal value ranges
That are different than your standard range
So we're trying to catch disease process or let's say dysfunction process before it becomes an emergency room visit
That's the whole idea. Now in our odx software
You'll see the large box if you get your blood work done through us. You'll see this large
What that I just took a clip out of proteins here and it shows total proteins
Album in globulins and an album in globulin ratio. This is what our software through odx software looks like
So it gives you a nice colorful picture
Then this example this person has a total protein of 8.2 that would be above the standard reference range
Remember different standard lab ranges can vary
But it's certainly way above our optimal range. So it's in the above optimal range the other
Total the album it is an optimal range in this example
globulin total globulins is above the optimal range and
And AG ratio is below optimal. So this is what our software looks like
If you get a whole giant picture of all your lab ranges in our software, but I just took a clip out of proteins
What's the significance of total protein?
So high levels of total protein
That is above 7.4 is more likely to be increased in the globulin fraction than the albumin fraction
Can be different, but it's that's the most likely unless there's dehydration that's causing this and remember
We're going to have a whole section of dehydration
But total protein elevation can be a side of dehydration can be a side of liver or gallbladder dysfunction as well
Low ranges in total protein can be hypochloridria
And you're going to see a lot of these labs do point to hypochloridria
Remember hypochloridria is a decrease in hydrochloric acid production
And if you watch the previous video you noted that I said something like I believe that it's probably the number one
Issue worldwide certainly in America and it can lead to a lot of dysfunction digestive dysfunction in our body
When we can't break down or digest
Nutrients in the stomach and it can lead to H. Pylori growth and I have a whole blog post on that too
So make sure you check that out
hypochloridria is
The first thing really that a person should check out when they're having
Any health issues you should address hypochloridria
Because that's most likely a piece of it. I'm not saying it's a cause of everything
But it's certainly a piece that you need to check out
Low total protein can be tied to digestive dysfunction
And or inflammation if you got a absorbing male absorption issues
Inflammation can decrease total protein liver dysfunction protein deficiency. Let's versus not eating protein
Maybe they're on a vegan diet. They're not getting adequate protein
Poor protein breakdown of course when you're not breaking down your proteins into amino acids
You're not going to be absorbing them and making new proteins that you need in your body that would be shown
in this test
And obviously malnutrition versus that eat
And they just need protein consumption amino acid need
Now the difference in these proteins we're looking at albumubin levels
Again this in this white box your standard reference range
American units international units second line
Optimal range is tighter. So our optimal functional range is our tighter
Albumin is primarily made in the liver therefore levels
Are affected by liver function. So liver dysfunction is going to affect albumin levels
Helps with water distribution albumin acts as a hormone transport protein
transports testosterone primarily
High levels of albumin under blood tests can point to dehydration or over hydration
And I mean excess hydration
So excess hydration leads to dehydration. That's why I put that in there
Low levels of albumin are tied to hypochloridria low HCl production
Because you're not breaking down the protein in your gut in order to absorb
amino acids to make albumin
Your liver dysfunction oxidative stress like toxic exposure and things
Vitamin C deficiency and it can lead to ademia and tied to adema
common with people with serious disease like cancer as well
total globulence so total globulence is what you're going to see on a cdc
A complete metabolic panel
And it is composed of different fractions of the globulin molecules
If they're elevated you can ask to run a protein electrophoresis test
That's not as commonly done. It's certainly not a normal test done, but that will give you a breakdown of
The fraction that is really causing issues
Because it's tied to different problems. It's made in the liver and in the cells
Helps with transport of proteins in blood
It's elevated with hypochloridria again liver damage liver dysfunctions cirrhosis can
Elevate globulence levels immune activation will elevate
a globulence
oxidative stress toxicity
Poisons you're exposed to different toxins heavy metals chemicals
Foodborne toxins can elevate globulence if you have a sensitivity real common
When you see a spike in globulence you it can be a sensitivity to a drug
So a medication that a person is taking or even a supplement they can have a sensitivity to
It can really cause a spike in globular levels you got to look at that as well
Low globular levels digestive issues inflammation same thing as albumin
You know immune insufficiency
Especially if your gamma globulence are low
If you do the electrophoresis test
The BUN is the blood urea nitrogen. It is actually the ratio between the production and the clearance of
urea
It's made in the liver urea is the final product of protein breakdown
It is a screen for renal insufficiency and for liver dysfunction
It's a screen for digestive issues and dehydration
It's elevated if there's an increased production of it in the liver or a decrease excretion
Of urea in the kidneys so therefore it's a sign of renal disease
It's tied to hypochloridria
It is a sign of excess protein, dietary protein intake
That can elevate it
Adrenal stress because cortisol will increase BUN
dysbiosis in the gut can affect BUN
Adema will affect BUN if the person has a sideys
There are blood urea nitrogen can be elevated
Enter pituitary dysfunction can cause this because of the hormones that are made there
It's decreased if the person has low dietary
protein intake
That malabsorption issues
Paygriatin insufficiency
Liver dysfunction posterior pituitary dysfunction
So
another sign of
Digestive issues as well
And then the ag ratio
This ratio is elevated if there's an increase in blood viscosity poor vascular tone
The person is sedentary they have let's say chronic disease
And they're just not getting up and moving around you could have an elevation in ag ratio
If the person is elderly and they're
You know in a bed in a nursing home
It can be a side of dehydration as well
It is
Depressed if there's liver dysfunction
It can be depressed in immune activation it can be depressed in
With decreased blood viscosity if there's if the person's taking a daily aspirin
Maybe taking too much of that taking unnecessary blood thinners
That's a sign of
You know excess use of blood thinners
Eocidophils again seemingly a little bit out of place because they're a white blood cell
Why are we talking about white blood cells?
We're talking about digestive markers
Because they are tied to intestinal parasites
They're tied to food allergies
Food sensitivities
When you have antibodies to different foods that you're having a
High reaction
They can't be tied to environmental allergies
Toxins in the environment that are causing an eosinophilic
elevation
They eosinophils also digest antibody
Intigent complexes therefore they're tied to later stages of inflammation so they can show late stage inflammation as well
They're high again in intestinal parasites
Things that I just spoke about food sensitivities
Allergies environmental things in it's common to be elevated in asthma patients
Amylase is an enzyme anything you see ASE at the end means it's an enzyme
Well amylase is the enzyme that breaks down carbohydrates
We spoke about this a little bit in our last video. It's made in the salivary glands and in the pancreas. It digests
I skipped that that part doesn't digest antibody complexes. It's it's really a carbohydrate
Breaks down large carbohydrates into sugars. That's a whole purpose of
Amylase it can be elevated with paicreatitis, especially with acute paicreatitis
And it can be elevated with issues with the salivary gland, tumors and things
Low in paicreatic insufficiency and issues with the salivary gland. So
Contrast that to lipase lipase is an enzyme that breaks down fats
We talk about elevation it
I said that amylase can be elevated in paicreatitis typically acute paicreatitis lie paces elevated in acute and chronic tends to hate out
longer than then amylase
So look at that, especially as the person is going to have very acute abdominal pain
paicreatitis can be very serious and needs to be treated right away if it's an infection
It can be with issues of the gallbladder and it's low with paicreatic insufficiency
Mypaces an enzyme that breaks down fats. It's made in the paicreatis and in the liver
The paicreatitis was made in the paicreatis and the salivary glands and when you start to chew your food
Amylase starts to break down carbohydrates
Well, lipase is not expressed until we get down to
the duodenum. So when food goes into the mouth and down the suffocates into the stomach
You're really breaking down proteins, you're breaking down carbohydrates
You don't really start breaking down fats until it gets into the small intestine
Where it's met with lipase enzymes from the paicreatis through the paicreatic duct
and from from the
gallbladder
secretes lipase that was bound to bile that was actually made in the liver so the liver makes lipase as well
transports it through the bile
through the common bile duct
with the paicreatic lipase to the duodenum the first part of the small intestine
to digest fats and where there's fats
remember physiology where there's an increase of fat
in the duodenum the gallbladder will contract and
squirt more bile in there give you the excess amount of lipase to break down that fat when you have
absence of a gallbladder you just have a trickle of lipase that's produced in the liver
in the liver in the liver that's um
entering the duodenum and um it can you know feed a fatty meal
with the absence of a gallbladder could be some insufficient breakdown of fats that's why
taking digestive enzymes particularly lipase um and some bile salts can be helpful
if you do not have a gallbladder to help break down fatty meals um
it's elevated with paicreatitis i said and paicreatic insufficiency is your main common um
lipase deficiency typically you won't see a lipase deficiency with gallbladder removal
because you're still making it in the liver and you're still transporting it into the small intestine
you're just not getting the concentration of it after you eat a fatty meal you're just getting
this trickle of transport from the liver um we still have a common mild doctor you just don't have
a gallbladder so you won't see the press levels of lipase because you have a gallbladder
removal surgery so that's not an issue okay so that gives you just a brief overview of some of the
tests that you'll see in the cbc the acidophils and the complete metabolic pedal
that um tie-to digestion will be getting into more specific conditions in our next video so
continue learning bye bye